-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're all doing well
and now, we're going
to get to the news.
President Biden was caught
on a hot microphone yesterday
referring to Fox News reporter
Peter Doocy
as "a stupid son of a bitch."
[ Laughter ]
Said Biden, "I am so sorry.
That was supposed to be
into the main mic."
[ Laughter ]
After he was caught referring
to Fox News reporter Peter Doocy
as "a stupid son of a bitch,"
President Biden reportedly
called Doocy to clear the air
and, just like
Biden being elected,
Doocy's going to pretend
it never happened.
[ Laughter ]
And, to me, the crazy part
of all this
isn't that Biden got mad
that Doocy tried
to make him look bad.
It's that Biden was so surprised
that Doocy tried
to make him look bad.
Where you been, dude?
[ Laughter ]
That's the game.
Biden's like that kid
in fourth grade
who wanted to play dodgeball
and then got super mad that
someone whipped a ball at him.
[ Laughter ]
As tensions increase
between the U.S. and Russia,
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki warned yesterday
that American citizens
in Ukraine
should leave the country now,
but added that no organized
evacuation is planned.
Why is that, because of the
last one you organized?
[ Audience ohs ]
We'd love to help out!
"We're good!"
[ Laughter ]
Just going to go on Expedia,
thank you.
Yesterday marked the start
of tax season,
for those who celebrate.
[ Laughter ]
NASA announced yesterday
that the world's largest
and most powerful telescope
has reached its observation post
and is now one million miles
away from Earth.
Must be nice.
[ Laughter ]
Hilton announced yesterday
that its Homewood Suites chain
of hotels
is now 100% pet-friendly,
while Days Inn announced
they have enough animals
to worry about.
[ Laughter ]
It's nice to see two raccoons
and a snake getting along.
[ Laughter ]
It's an uneasy peace!
Krispy Kreme will offer
a dozen free doughnuts
to anyone who donates blood,
amid a national shortage.
Tough break for anyone
who drank it already.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
Guys are out a dozen doughnuts.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a couple in India
recently announced
that they will have their
wedding in the metaverse
and have invited 2,000 people.
It's the perfect way to say,
"We don't want our grandparents
to come."
[ Laughter ]
"It's in the what?!"
And that was the monologue,
everybody!